hi guys dr. Burke here in this video
we're gonna talk about the heated
debates going on between being a
meat-eater versus being a vegan okay and
it really boils down to if you're a
meat-eater you're saying carbs are
dangerous and if you're a vegan you're
saying animal fats and protein are
dangerous so the real problem is you
have two groups two different viewpoints
giving conflicting information and if
you're the public trying to figure out
the truth you're in this confusion okay
a confusion is conflicting information
so I really believe the big problem is
the interpretation of the actual
research and studies that are being put
out there in order to understand these
studies you personally would have to
read them and understand them and you
would need a medical dictionary you
would need some basic understanding of
medical physiology so that's where it
stops right there so then you have to
rely on some other person's
interpretation of the study which then
comes with certain biases so then the
question is what is the truth what is
the true knowledge in order to have
certainty on knowledge you have to have
personal experience okay because someone
can show you tons of success stories
tons of studies but unless you
personally experience this information
and it works for you you're not going to
have the full certainty so here's what I
think you should do you should try this
for a while okay see the results that
you get then try this diet for a while
and compare the results and see which
one works better for you what produced
the most results wait blood profiles
improvement in energy and overall
quality of health then you'll have the
certainty what works for you and you
won't have to be dependent on some third
party viewpoint or some study because
you experienced it hey guys I want to
personally invite you to a new Facebook
group that I just started called dr.
Berg's Kido and in a minute fasting lab
ok so I created this so we can share our
successful actions what worked what
didn't work the results so I put
link down below so go ahead and sign up
and I'll see you inside